welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series and get the free bonus
companion worksheets that go with this
video check the link in the description
below alright today is day 14 and we're
gonna learn how you can overcome failure
[Music]
you cannot invent and pioneer if you
cannot accept failure its YouTube to
invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know in advance that it's
going to work it is not an experiment
and so that's a very important thing you
know it's these they're inseparable
twins failure and invention so you have
to be willing to do that
it's embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
with a particular decision a 10% chance
of a 100x return you should take that
bet every time but you're still gonna be
wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine hundred ten times
and in in in with technology the
outcomes the results can be very long
tailed they it's very at the payoff is
can be very asymmetric which is why you
should do so much experimentation you
know everybody knows that if you swing
for the fences you hit more home runs
but you also strike out more but with
the baseball that analogy doesn't go far
enough because with baseball no matter
how well you connect with the ball you
can only get four runs the success is
capped at four runs but in business
every once in a while you step up to the
plate you hit the ball so hard you get a
thousand runs and so when that when you
have that kind of asymmetric payoff and
you know one app one app back and get
you a thousand runs it encourages you to
experiment more it's the right business
decision to experiment more it's also
better for your customers customers like
the successful experiments failure is
part of life I mean
the difference for me though is I like a
failure as a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm gonna fail
but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability to influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that mess me up
but I show people that didn't let it
stop me and you don't need to stop you
and I think I think that's really the
secret matter and if everything you
touch was successful
first got to relate to people as well oh
you'll be late and also it's be total
bullsh and everyone know it's bullsh and
also you'd be bored silly I mean think
about it if you just said I want this
and happen I want this to happen you
know people don't value it they don't
fight for you know it's like you see
kids sometimes in it you know your
parents will say you're not gonna value
this if you don't work for it and you're
keeping going
value just give it to me but it's true
you know about things we've worked the
hardest for we value the most so I think
you know the purpose of the goal is not
getting it anyway the purpose of goal
you know is what who you become who you
becomes gonna make you happier it's
gonna make you sad so I'm not looking
for an effortless approach there's no
such thing what was your biggest failure
and how did I change you to really think
hard about that failure there's your
answer here well there's a ton of
failures along the way that's for sure
like I said as a support for SpaceX the
first three launches failed and we were
just barely able to scrape together
enough parts and money to do the fourth
launch that both launch should fail who
would have been dead so multiple
failures along the way I tried very hard
to get the right expertise in for for
SpaceX I tried hard to to find a great
chief engineer for the rocket but it not
the good chief engineers wouldn't join
and the bad ones will there's no no
point in hiring them so I ended up being
chief engineer of the rocket
so if I could have found somebody better
then we would have maybe had less than
three failures how do you turn failure
into a plus and it's true when I was in
the University of Nebraska one day I was
reading the daily Nebraskan and it said
in room 303 o'clock there will be this
panel of three professors here at the
University and they're going to award
the Nathan gold scholarship I don't know
whether you still you still have been
around and at the time it said it would
give you five hundred dollars to go to
the graduate school of your choice I
don't know whether it's changing the
mountain but that that was it so I read
this and I went there to this room at
three o'clock that day or whatever it
was and I walked in the room and there
were the professors and I was the only
student that showed up I mean it really
got to him I mean anything they were
stuck they you know they kept waiting
and looking at their watch and hoping
there'd be more candidates but there no
one came in so I won $500 budget by
default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up and so here I
was I had $500 to go toward any it
wasn't it was the limited as any any
graduate school for a master's degree so
I applied to Harvard my dad wanted me to
and i shortly heard from harvard and
they said go to chicago and meet this
fellow running that who interviews
applicants from the Midwest so I got on
the train that's what you did in those
days and I spent on 10 hours on the
Burlington going to Chicago then I
transferred to another little inner
urban train to go up to this country day
school where this fellow was the
headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for Harvard and I got there
and after about 10 minutes he he said
better think about something else uh you
know he come back later on I was I was
19 at the time and I looked about 12 you
know and and I and I acted about eight
it was not a great combination but so he
said forget it
so I spent a little dinner urban train
back to Chicago and I took the 10-hour
train back to Omaha all the time hey you
know what do I tell my parents you know
it's kind of embarrassing but it was it
was the luckiest thing ever happened to
me I because if I'd gone to Harvard I
would have gone to a two-year business
school I instead applied to Columbia
where I could graduate in one year and
get a masters degree luckily that by the
accident of it and being in the Nebraska
National Guard which did not get called
up with a Korean War I missed going in
the Korean War I I got to meet Ben
Graham and which had an enormous effect
on me subsequently and I probably got my
wife that way because she was going to
Darth Western and I was able to put on
sort of a full-court press because I got
one year and otherwise she'd she'd have
met some other guy I mean I got her
before the competition showed up and
it worked out wonderfully it couldn't
have worked out better and that's been
that's been my life basically I mean it
the things you know you will get some
disappointments you know what the future
is what counts would be fun if I knew
every decision I was going to make was
going to be perfect it would not be as
much fun he liked playing golf and
knowing you're gonna hit a hole-in-one
on every hole you wouldn't play golf if
every time you got out of tea you just
took a swing of the ball ended up in the
hole yeah be fun for a few days you get
get on TV but the game would not be any
fun so its failure you know and I
wouldn't even consider and failures but
there are mistakes you whatever you want
us we call it their part of the game and
in the end you know you go on and and we
made plenty of mistakes in business
we'll make plenty more and then you know
the Babe Ruth and you know for a long
time it subsequently got eclipsed by a
few fellows but he held the record for
strikeouts and also the hell the record
for home runs in his eyes by baseball
player until the modern error came along
and so it's it's part of the game if you
take big swings you know you it may you
may you're gonna miss sometimes most
people who are failing are trying to ass
off yeah most people were feeling of
being criticized by people who haven't
attempted which are even trying to fail
at so when I'm feeling that so that's a
pity I did 2500 pull up it's my first
time now going for the record
yep any people we're criticizing me
people sitting there eating chips on the
couch do a pull-up exactly look at your
audience who's criticizing you first of
all yeah they're not even in your world
yes you don't even talk to me
yeah block him out that's the first
thing yeah the second thing is to
failure you get all the answers you get
all the lessons all of them yes they're
all there yes so I was able to go back
through is okay this happened this
happened this was wrong this is wrong
this is wrong so I don't even look at
fail you're like I didn't call it
failure yeah I I don't because I don't
look it like my god I failed no I look
at okay like trying to omit the light
bulb I'm afraid you know what but what's
failure I'm trying to pin a light bulb
yeah I'm trying to break 4020
pull-ups hmm that's failure yeah
anything you do along that way is
amazing growing up my dad used to
encourage my brother and me to fail so
at the dinner table he would actually
ask us what did you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and I can remember coming home from
school and me like dad dad I tried out
for this and I was horrible at he'd be
like way to go and high-five and what it
was such a gift what he was doing I
didn't realize that at the time but he
was redefining failure for me and so
failure became not about the outcome but
about not trying and so you know the
fear of failure as we all know as
entrepreneurs is one of the greatest
fears in life it's one of the things
that stops us in our tracks and keeps us
from trying something and so I you know
I incorporate that in my philosophy at
Spanx we have we celebrate failures we
talk about them we have oops meetings
we're all announced the oops that I have
and sometimes we have fun with it we'll
even attach theme songs to our oops and
we'll play them in front of the whole
company but I think it's just so
important to try to get the people that
you work with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of I want to protect my job and feel
like I'm not safe if I make mistakes
tell us about failure and why it's
important to love it
yeah because I love it I like micro
failure I like micro failure
I hate macro failure like death of your
business is bad but but to me you know
it's funny I'll use a boxing analogy my
favorite boxing but I watch a lot of
boxing
I think boxing is a very interesting and
I know and I'm super into mixed martial
arts but I grew up on boxing I
understand it better and I like watching
it because there's so many things that
happen in boxing first of all what I
love about boxing is there's nowhere to
hide you know like it's super
interesting right there's nowhere to
hide number two there's something
there's a scenario boxing that I love
the most
there's for some reason there's nothing
more interesting to me than watching
somebody get knocked down in the first
round and then go on to win the fight
easily
it's an interesting psyche right and I
like that and this is what I'm thinking
about it which is like here's what's bad
in boxing and in business going into a
fight getting knocked the [ __ ] out in
the first round and losing the match bad
getting knocked down and then having the
adversity to readjust to what you got
caught on and navigating it too easily
when a fight is remarkable that's how I
think about entrepreneurship people the
reason so many people struggle with
entrepreneurship is you have micro
failures almost daily and they're very
in-your-face you can't hide and I like
that I like failure I because I think I
deserve it I hate when people don't
respect the game when I fail it means
I've thought and I like that because I
think people get audacious my number one
thing that I hate about capitalism is
that people use it and they love it and
they're big capitalists and they love
open market and competition and all that
and then they become 73 and they try to
use all their money to protect their
money they're not willing to let a young
lion eat them the way they ate somebody
else I hate when they try to manipulate
it that's what I love about sports what
I love about sports is when you're 36
and you were once the best player in the
league but now you're getting a little
bit older and your body breaks down you
are forced to retire the one thing that
entrepreneurship and capitalism has to
adjust to is once you get old and you're
tired and you want to be on a yacht
instead of working you're you should
lose some money because you're losing
when you think about your risk tolerance
for failure how far are you willing to
fail well I mean unfortunately
unfortunately I felt quite a bit okay
you know but I understand that's
actually part of the process of
succeeding I'm not one I really believe
in failure I believe you have setbacks
and you know you have to learn from
those you have to learn what are those
landmines that can be avoided the next
time
what are those pitfalls you have to
learn from that stuff and
so yeah welcome those things it's a part
of life but are you prepared to like
really fail at something totally new
like what if you're just VC then I wish
you see yeah you know and then I work at
it and then I'm not as you see the next
yeah you know whenever it happened yeah
listen aya my first year in the league
on national TV 18 years old got shot
five straight air balls in the playoffs
in front of millions of people yeah I
think my time is pretty high yeah yeah
think I'm alright
with respect to failure it's terrible
but but but necessary if you if you are
going to try something hard if you're
putting yourself out there in some way
there are going to be times where you
screw up or you don't succeed or there
are times where you do everything right
and you still don't succeed but that's
not just true of politics or running a
non-for-profit that's true some of you
talked about being entrepreneurial if
you're starting a clothing line that's
that's a cutthroat business yeah I'm
sure you yeah I have every confidence I
out of it you're gonna succeed at some
point but you'll go through some
failures you know and and I think that
the most important thing and and this is
a little bit of a cliche but sometimes
clichés are true is to learn from those
failures and to have a sense of
resilience and be able to examine what
is it that I did not succeed at why
didn't I succeed and what do I need to
do better if you're focused on giving of
yourself to accomplish something then
even when you fail at a particular
objective you're still succeeding in
learning about how you can accomplish
those goals you think about fear failure
what it really is is an illusion it
doesn't exist because even if because
even if you fail at something you still
learn something from it but no one could
take that
experience away from you so a lot of
that is all this mental potion that we
have that we are so afraid of I don't
know what if it doesn't work right
that's not very empowering question
right what if I don't know what how
would people think of me right what if I
lose money right what if my business
doesn't take off like a lot of what-ifs
and the reality is most of those things
don't actually happen it's this
programming this belief that we have
that we don't believe that's gonna work
and guess what if you don't believe is
gonna work what happens it doesn't work
I think there's like a thin film of
terror wrapped around us and so if it's
not I'm not safe enough I'm not secure
enough it's I'm not liked enough I'm not
promoted enough I'm not loved enough I
just have another have enough I am not
enough at the very bottom yeah I'm not
enough yeah well that's big big bag bag
bag bag somebody ring some bells we need
some bells to ring on this show but
that's it and so guess what the number
one casualty is of a scarcity culture
what vulnerability we shut down we shut
down cuz I'm not gonna let you know now
cuz I'm not all together right yeah and
the thing is that people like oh well we
lose a little vulnerability but
vulnerability is not just about fear and
grief and disappointment it's the
birthplace of everything we're hungry
for creativity joy creativity faith yeah
innovation and all of that yes and the
whole thing is there is no innovation
and creativity without failure period so
you got to be open enough to take the
risk to fail yeah have you ever thought
of scaling your way to success think
about that for a moment do you know that
anyone that enjoys any kind of success
feels their way there that's right they
do I want you to think of this for a
moment
see this little light here someone gave
me this as a gift this is a replica of
the light that Edison built and you know
he spent a long time before he got this
thing to glow he really did and he
started off because he had an image of
it in his mind that every time he tried
he failed and he failed 3,000 times has
been said no I've never really talked at
us and so I don't know if that's
accurate but I have an idea it is 3,000
failures now a reporter asked him on
time how he felt about failing 3,000
times he said didn't fail 3,000 times
he's there with 3,000 steps to get to
where I'm going you know if I were to
tell you all the sad stories about has
got me to where I am I would really
spoil your week and there's been some
real sad stories I think it might even
make me cry again but I've had so many
failures that I wouldn't even want to
guess at it I have I blown everything I
had three different times I never let it
bother me much and you know I have found
that every time I failed I move closer
to the goal to see if you knew how to do
it now you'd be going sideways when
you're going after a goal you're going
ahead and because you're going or you're
never being you're gonna make mistakes
you don't know it all you have
perfection within you and the objective
of life is to bring that perfection to
the surface that's exactly what this guy
did well you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes bringing that to the surface
those mistakes are steps to where you're
going up and tell salespeople that are
afraid to make a call just to go out
there and make a call and their
objective isn't to sell their
Objectivist just make the call if you
make the call and you're afraid and you
do it you're successful you've
accomplished what you want to do you
made a call and after you get
comfortable making those calls then you
can start to polish up your presentation
and odds are pretty good you'll start
making sales and if you keep polishing
up your presentation and working it
getting better you're gonna master a
thing called selling but if you think
that you're going to enjoy great success
it's just one win after another you're
kidding yourself it just doesn't happen
I don't even know anyone that's pulled
that kind of video laughs if they did
they were cheating or lying deciding to
make that iPod movie which was really
stupid and not a great movie that was
one of these defining moments and when
that guy is names Tom Scott he's a
brilliant entrepreneur when he turned to
me and said is there something bigger
you wanted to that was one of those
moments and when we pitched him was this
it was like hey why aren't you just bank
roll us cover all of our expenses for a
year and let us make a bunch of little
movies is not that not the dream right
but he seemed am edible I mean this is a
guy who was offering us a huge
opportunity after we had done nothing
but delivered on something that was
nothing like what he hired us for so it
was like maybe I want to take a chance
and he said sure let's do it by the way
him bankrolling us for a year was was
very very little amount of money it was
literally just enough so we would have
to worry about rent we're not talking
about millions of dollars here was
something small
and what we did that what we did then
was all we knew how to do which was make
these tiny little movies and this is
2007 but now in 2018 are described in as
essentially YouTube movies like that's
what we were doing but we didn't know
what they were just the only thing we
knew how to do so we made these little
videos and he would come once a month
and check on us just to make sure we
weren't completely blowing off this huge
deal that we made with him and he loved
the content and about six months and he
walked into our office with this like
very smart
big deal a movie producer and it was it
was like nerve-wracking her name is
Christine Bashan by the way she's a
Oscar award-winning producer she's an
incredible just like brilliant mind in
the world and she watched the content I
remember she like didn't say anything
which is like the worst thing somebody
can do you know somebody's I know that
sucks really try harder and if
somebody's like this is great someone
says nothing nothing is the scariest
thing and she said nothing and then when
it was over she turned and looked at us
and she goes
I think that that was very good but wait
let's perspect she didn't say I think
that was very good she said I think that
that was very good like she wasn't it
was more like what the hell did I just
watch
and she came back to us and she gave us
this piece of advice she was like take
all of those little movies and figure
out how to put them together in a
consumable way like make it so you can
actually watch them and we're like ok so
that's exactly we did we took all these
little pieces of a movie we made them 20
minutes long we put an intro at the
beginning and we put credits at the end
and then we were like this is now a TV
show do you laugh and so did every
single TV network we brought it to I
remember one network was like if you
don't find anywhere else to put it we'll
put it on our website and that was like
the most painful thing to hear I was
like defeat but that woman Christine
vishawn she showed it to HBO and I
remember her calling and we were like
hey how'd the meeting go and she said
they liked it and I just remember I was
like she's a restrained one but that has
to mean something they liked it and at
the end
HBO bought that show for like a couple
million dollars and that was like the
big break that was our big success don't
applaud that was our big success you
guys working on flawed anyways that was
it that was the victory 2008 like climb
on top of the mountaintop like we did it
and then nothing happened like they sat
on the show for two years and when it
finally aired two years later they
played it on a Friday night at midnight
can you imagine what this audience eyes
would be like if my videos were only
watchable at midnight on Friday nights
it'd be me and that guy with the phone
that's it
and it was it was a failure like it got
cool reviews people like this is an
interesting concept no and watch it and
that was crushing that was heartbreaking
it was in the ashes of that that I was
like you know I'm just gonna do this on
YouTube I'm just gonna do this on
YouTube and I think the ultimate irony
is that if you go back and you watch the
HBO series you'll see it feels and looks
exactly like the content that I now call
a vlog they're content that does two
million views a day every single day
it's the same thing so often you don't
move forward because you're keeping such
score from what didn't work in the past
you are holding yourself hostage to 1997
to 2005 you're holding yourself hostage
in love to that past relationship that
didn't work or you're holding yourself
in hostage in business to the money that
you may have thought you wasted or the
deal that went bad and so one of the
ways I give myself permission for two
two levels
permission to have lived a life that has
some beautiful experiences and some
really tangy lessons I mean they're
spicy they hurt they're painful when I
give myself permission to have had that
I also give myself permission to keep
leaping give myself permission to keep
dreaming give myself permission to keep
learning how to get it right learning
how to love the unlovable forgive what
seems to be the unforgivable to leap
again even while I still have a bandage
on my chin from the last time I fell I
still get to leave someone invite you if
you fall fall catch your breath put a
bandage on it whether you fail
financially you fail physically with
health and wellness you felt spiritually
you felt emotionally you felt in a
relationship okay a part of flying is
understanding what the distinction
between flying and falling and the only
way you understand the distinction is
that you experience full life when you
experience full life it's like this life
isn't just flatline is not just like
this you make your Heights feel better
because you understand this was a
failure
and and what I mean by a failures this
taught me a lesson this stung this every
single failure has a lesson in it to me
a failure is a lesson wrapped in and and
some sticky icky paper that stung that
hurt and so give yourself permission
give yourself permission to play big to
be nervous to fall down to sit down for
a minute
just don't take up real estate in the
sitting down don't take up real estate
in the analyzing don't take don't take
up real estate in the preparation you've
been getting prepared for a long time
for something trust that you'll either
fly if you leap right now or your fall
if you leak right now and if you fly
you'll understand what soaring feels
like and if you fall you'll understand
what getting up feels like either way
you're okay that's how I play big with
my knees knocking that's how I play big
even when there's something in my in my
consciousness reminding me of the last
time I did something like this and it
didn't quite work out and I still play
big because I gave myself I give myself
I constantly give myself permission to
totally win and soar are totally falling
it up
and that way there's nothing to truly be
afraid of remember this is a dialogue
not a monologue which means we're in a
dynamic conversation versus me just
entertaining you there is no ceiling for
you really there's nothing you can't I
don't think there's a I mean all are
your sillas anyone there's no ceiling
you know because I mean you've proven
that you can you can cover the whole
waterfront in terms of kinds of
characters yeah whether the it's a boxer
or a quadriplegic or someone it was a
brilliant lawyer the whole range of
stuff mm-hmm you know with the training
that I had that's the way we were
trained you know to play any part isn't
there's no such thing as you can't play
a party may not be right for a
particular part yeah but I don't think
there's a part I can't attempt to play I
could at least analyze and try to break
down and put a performance together he
not being he could yeah but I was taught
one of the things that I was taught that
sticks in my mind was a gentleman by the
name of Bill ball who was the artistic
director in American Conservatory
Theater in San Francisco and he always
talked about failing big so if you're
gonna fail fail big and I'm like I like
that for I do too I did you know I'm not
a fallback mentality kind of person
people would say well you know you
better have another career to fall back
on I'm like I don't want to fall back on
anything if I fall I'm gonna fall
forward I want to see what I'm hitting
or buy you exactly you know what I mean
I don't wanna burn I never understood
that mentality neither I never
understood it I'm like I'm going that
way yeah I mean if you worry about being
safe and secure and you know there's
security
well if security is your by word then
you know you're gonna you're never gonna
reach out and do anything I don't think
that's gonna protect you that's right
you know it's gonna give you any kind of
genuine satisfaction
you know if you could be worried about
that then you know it was no lie in
other words if you're a sailor you would
never leave port right I only care about
security
there was an IQ the question I think was
an IQ question where they had nine dots
yeah and you had to connect the dots I
think with five lines without lifting
the pencil the only way you could do it
was to go outside the box
yeah you know people sit there with
intugo man that's right you can't do it
what you can't nobody said you can't go
outside the box yeah in the middle of
2009 he was the software engineer that
no one wanted to hire he had 12 years of
experience at Yahoo but he was rejected
by Facebook and then rejected by Twitter
he'd been to a great university he had a
great CV but he decided to team up with
one of his alumni members at Yahoo and
started to create an app and focus on
the startup space in five years time he
sold that out for 19 billion dollars to
Facebook believe it or not that was
Brian Acton the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from Facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people I
look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by Twitter he
responded by saying worked-out ills by a
long commute it's so interesting to see
that someone rejected from two of the
top Internet companies actually
responded with humor and actually
responded with positivity this lady was
diagnosed with clinical depression her
marriage had failed and she was jobless
with a dependent child she was on a
four-hour delayed train journey from
Manchester to London when she came up
with this idea and she started to write
this book about this wizard and as she
started writing she then finished her
manuscript to get to 12 publishers and
was rejected by all of 12 believe it or
not that's JK Rowling this man watched
his first company crumble he was a
Harvard University dropout and his first
company's demo didn't even work he went
on to build Microsoft his name's Bill
Gates
therefore failure is just a sign that we
need to widen our scope we need to be
ready and build ourselves up for the
next level actually what we end up
achieving is far greater than what we'd
envisioned for ourselves and this divine
plan this orchestration can't be
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we
just settle
except what we thought was our goal what
we thought we were chasing but actually
I've noticed that when you don't get
that later down the line you look back
and you reflect and realize that what
you've gained is so much greater failure
is only failures when we don't learn
from them because when we learn from
them they become lessons and we actually
extract aller all of these teachings and
actually get more insight into how we
can improve the way we work and how we
can actually drive with a different
energy the challenge we have is that we
only talk about people's failures when
they succeed and that's why they become
this taboo or we feel like their
failures never happened we need to share
these stories earlier we need to bring
out these stories and experiences on the
journey so that people who are on the
journey can actually follow in those
footsteps
and that's why Steve Jobs said you can't
connect the dots moving forward
you only can when you're looking
backwards now I've got a special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the best live
30 questions of the day it's not enough
to just watch this video you have to do
something so pull out your worksheets
and answer these questions and if you
don't have the worksheets you can get
them for free check the link in the
description below all right here we go
question number one what did you learn
from your failures that you can turn
into a plus number two what do you want
to do next but you're afraid you're
gonna fail at number three how can you
minimize the risk of failure and just
get started and if you are doing the
best live 30 challenge with me give me a
hashtag best live 30 in the comments
below so I can celebrate with you
most people don't feel enough most
people are so afraid of a huge field
that they don't even try you're afraid
of taking a big bet you're afraid of
going into deep debt and that fear
prevents you from having the thing that
matters the most right now in your
business momentum you don't need to feel
big but you do need to start otherwise
you will never build the big business
that you're capable of building so I'm a
big fan of going from idea to action
idea to action idea to action idea to
actually get an idea what do you do you
take
teach yourself train yourself as soon as
you get that idea don't judge it don't
think about it don't plan and ponder and
strategize because your list of ideas is
a mile long and it's not going to get
any shorter you're a genius you come up
with great ideas
you're gonna keep coming with ideas for
the rest of your life that list of ideas
is not gonna shrink so how do you start
moving you take action I call the 2%
difference instead of planning to get
100% for your idea what's the 2%
difference that you can just do
something about right now I think your
ideas came to you for a reason
I think it's inspired why are you
thinking about this thing don't judge
the reason just go off and do something
one small conversation one small action
start building momentum that's the thing
that's missing right now is momentum you
need more momentum you're a genius you
have great ideas
you should be changing the world what's
missing is momentum and I want you to
find it if you want to join the best
like 30 challenge for free click the
link right here below me or if you want
more videos on how to overcome failure
check out the playlist right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there